de l'innovation française qui permet aux
personnes dyslexiques de pouvoir lire
sans aucun problème alors pour vous
expliquer si vous n'êtes pas dyslexique
une personne dyslexique elle va lire
comme ça et c'est extrêmement compliqué
pourquoi parce qu'en fait elle a deux
yeux dominants et elle va venir recréer
au niveau cérébral une espèce de double
image au niveau du texte qui lui permet
pas de lire dans des conditions
optimales la science a trouvé une
solution c'est grâce à un effet
stroboscopique vous allez pouvoir
recréer artificiellement un oeil
dominant et de retrouver un confort de
lecture comme une personne qui n'est pas
dyslexique il y a une boîte française
qui s'appelle Lili for Life qui a créé
une petite lampe qu'on peut emmener
partout avec soi qui s'appelle Lili et
qui va pouvoir générer en effet
stroboscopique et qui permet justement
aux personnes dyslexique de pouvoir lire
comme si elle n'était pas dyslexique le
truc qui est génial vous avez votre
lampe qui est couplé à une application
en Bluetooth bien évidemment vous allez
pouvoir trouver la bonne fréquence tu
vas venir corriger le problème produit
on peut le trouver dans le commerce Fnac
Darty et compagnie mais également sur
leur site Lili for life.com si vous vous
êtes même d'ailleurs dyslexique ou si
vous connaissez des personnes ça
pourrait intéresser d'ailleurs ça les
intéresse n'hésitez pas à les taguer
comme ça ils pourront venir découvrir la
solution